allez on va démarrer
comme d'habitude on fait
cette fête en fin d'année en réunit tous
les enfants du quartier des quartiers la
Bretagne la montagne
de 410
club il va voir le Père Noël et un gros
événement qui va arriver ça c'est sûr
les parents pour leur participation lors
de merci
est-ce que les entraîneurs m'ont dit
il a tout le mort fautif du Père Noël
c'est parfait on l'a trouvé vraiment le
bon cette année
je suis un petit peu baigné je me suis
amusé et voilà
la Réunion en direct de la Corée du Sud
où j'étais pour le Grand Prix de Jeju
j'ai réussi à m'imposer mais pas je vous
dis à très bientôt à très vite le 11 et
14 février chez vous pour échanger pour
passer des bons moments et surtout une
belle expérience niveau judo à bientôt
sur les bateaux
c'est un défi c'est vrai que ça nous
paraissait un peuable c'est un rêve défi
qu'on s'est lancé donc le directeur
technique et moi et la petite anecdote
tout est parti d'un simple texto
à l'agent Teddy Riner parce
qu'effectivement on n'a jamais pu
jusqu'à présent lui parler qui est son
frère aujourd'hui et puis de fil en
aiguille des liens sont créés et qui
font qu'aujourd'hui ce projet va se
réaliser
du monde c'est le plus grand champion de
l'univers du judo